[Music]
the fate of yet another police officer
involved in the death of a black man has
yet to be determined the first trial of
officer William G Porter one of six
police officers involved in the death of
Baltimore resident Freddie gray ended
with a hung jury and a mistrial since
last year's police shooting of unarmed
teen Michael Brown in Ferguson and the
growth of the black lives matter
movement we're more aware than ever of
just how many black men in America died
at the hands of police but what happens
to the officers let's take a look back
at some of the major officer-involved
deaths of black men in the last 18
months and where those officers are
today first there's Michael Brown an
unarmed 18-year old who was shot to
death by Officer Darren Wilson in
Ferguson Missouri
officer Wilson got off scot-free he was
not indicted for his role in the
shooting and was cleared of any civil
rights violations
the Department of Justice later found
the police department to have routinely
used excessive force against the city's
african-american residents and the
police chief stepped down the month
before Brown's death another unarmed
black man named Eric garner died on
Staten Island after an officer put him
in a chokehold a maneuver that the
police department had banned the police
had confronted garner on the suspicion
he was selling untaxed cigarettes
although the coroner pronounced Garner's
at the homicide the grand jury did not
indict officer Daniel Pantaleo today
Pantaleo remains on the police force on
a modified assignment until the
conclusion of a civil rights
investigation which could lead to either
prison or fines
it's not that officers never get
indicted earlier this year when officer
Michael Slager shot Walter Scott in the
back in Charleston South Carolina
Slager was indicted for murder though
Slager claimed he fired his gun because
Scott had reached for the officers taser
cellphone video showed there was no
violent struggle Officer Slager is now
sitting in a jail in South Carolina
awaiting trial and more than a year
after 17 year-old laQuan McDonald was
shot 16 times by Officer Jason van Dyke
in Chicago van Dyke was charged with
first degree murder but
took 13 months for the dashcam video of
the incident to be released during which
time vend I continued to work for the
Chicago Police Department
today van Dyke is out on bail while he
waits for trial and because the charge
of first-degree murder requires proof
beyond a reasonable doubt that the
murder was premeditated there are doubts
that the charges against Van Dyke will
even hold up in court there are so many
more cases like these Tamir rice Samuel
DuBose Mario woods the list of names is
long the national conversation has
pointed to a broken policing system that
favors those in power so is there any
hope well Mike Brown's hometown of
Ferguson is nearing a deal with the
Justice Department to make much-needed
changes in their policing system of
course those changes come at a high
price and it's still unclear if the city
can afford to pay for them so when will
we make it a priority to fix our justice
system to be fair for all
[Music]